the healthcare debate yesterday on CNN
was interesting but the proposal appears
to be dead so I'm not really feeling the
need to go through the debate point by
point but the long and short of it was
it was a debate between senators Graham
and Cassidy who are the proposers the
the sponsors of the Trump Care 3.0 bill
they were trying to defend their bill
despite the reality that it would be a
horrific bill and they were being they
were debating senators Bernie Sanders
and Amy Klobuchar and Sanders and
Klobuchar were there to explain why
Cassidy Graham Cassidy would be bad it
also provided an opportunity for Bernie
Sanders to talk about his Medicare for
all 2017 bill and lots of what was said
by the Republicans like I predicted used
weasel language and it's it's just the
normal stuff that we expected and are
used to one example of that is Senator
Cassidy at one point when asked about
pre-existing conditions coverage he said
we think our bill has the same
pre-existing conditions protections as
Obamacare so the use of the word we
think as opposed to the bill has the
same pre-existing conditions coverage as
Obamacare that is weasel language okay
but there was one specific thing that
senator Cassidy kept bringing up he
mentioned it it must have been five six
or seven times during the CNN healthcare
debate yesterday
sounded like a broken record and I want
to explore it because it's either true
or it's not and the talking point from
Cassidy was that there's someone
somewhere in his home state of Louisiana
paying close to $40,000 a year for
health care okay he said it during the
debate he's tweeted about it here he is
telling the story on Fox News he talks
about this all the time there's a fella
back home with a special-needs child
he's paying over $40,000 a year over
40,000 a year for his premiums has to
have insurance has a special-needs child
and it's estimated his premium goes up
20% this next year that does not take
care of a striver it does not take care
of somebody whose child has a
pre-existing condition our bill gives us
state the opportunity to do something
that does okay is that true I mean is it
even possible to have premiums of
$40,000 a year under Obama Obama care
this is a great opportunity to
fact-check things right good thing to do
let's analyze what we're being told so
first of all is Cassidy talking about
$40,000 in premiums or $40,000 in total
costs for health care we don't know we
don't know 40,000 for total costs for a
family of four is sadly possible but
that's because of the system we have
more broadly getting rid of Obamacare
wouldn't actually change that and Graham
Cassidy wouldn't improve that at all
so let's assume the story is $40,000 a
year for health insurance health
insurance premiums 40,000 a year what do
we know Cassidy has told us that this is
a man and his special-needs child that
they live back home in Louisiana so
that's insurance in Louisiana and
presumably this is a guy who has a high
enough income not to get subsidies
although again we don't really know what
Cassidy is talking about so the
assertions are 40k a year and the
premiums are set to go up 20% we don't
know where in Louisiana he lives so you
can run numbers on healthcare.gov for
someone living in Orleans Parish that's
where New Orleans is presumably it's the
most expensive part of the state the
most expensive policy that Charles gabba
on his website ACA signups dotnet was
able to find assuming that the family is
just the dad and the special-needs kid
the dad is 40 the kid is 10 years old is
the Blue Cross Blue Shield blue max plan
which is a gold PPO plan 1172 per month
fifty four hundred dollar deductible
fourteen thousand three hundred dollar
limit out of pocket that's the one
that's been on the screen that we've
been showing you that's fourteen
thousand for the year not forty thousand
fourteen thousand what if we come up
with a way to make it even more
expensive right rerun the signup
imagining that the family is the dad a
spouse the ten-year-old special needs
kid and another eight year old kid now
the most expensive possible plan is
twenty three hundred forty five dollars
a month well now we're at twenty eight
thousand dollars for the year we're
closer but still Cassidy is talking
about 40 grand what if we make all four
family members older and make one of
them a smoker
well that
27:52 a month all right that's $33,000
per year
still not the 40,000 that Cassidy is
talking about well what if they have
three kids three thousand one hundred
and forty two dollars per month $37,000
but still not there and here's the
kicker if you have a family of five you
would get a subsidy for a household
income up to a hundred and sixteen
thousand dollars per year we don't know
what this guy makes but even if he made
a hundred thousand dollars a year he
would get a subsidy which would make the
plan actually cheaper there are almost
no scenarios where the $40,000 would
happen ACA signups dotnet was able to
find one one and that was if you had a
48 year old parent who's a smoker
another 48 year old parent three kids
and a household income of over a hundred
and sixteen thousand dollars a year that
would get you two three thousand four
hundred and three dollars per month
that's 40 grand but that is an
incredibly rare and specific case and by
the way smoking is optional so what
about being the party of personal
responsibility but I actually believe
that the 40 grand is a distraction
because the real question is whether it
exists or not what will we do about it
and would Graham Cassidy fix it and it
wouldn't in fact it would eliminate the
subsidies of Obamacare it would replace
them with smaller amounts of money
through block grants and it none of it
actually makes sense so it's a major
distraction and it also ignores that
regardless of income depending on the
condition of this ten-year-old special
needs kid that they might qualify for
Medicaid regardless of income so it is
so dishonest to present this without any
more information because it is almost
impossible that this is actually real
you can actually make a change though to
the current system if the $40,000
example really exists you can make a
change to it in the short run you can
beef up and raise the eligibility cap
for those Obamacare tax credits to win
include people earning more than four
times the federal poverty line that is a
specific change you could make now if
Democrats and Republicans said hey we
have Obamacare even though we disagree
about what we should eventually have
here are specific tweaks to Obamacare
that we can make but instead we've got
40 grand assertions from Cassidy with no
actual explanation as to who that family
is or why they're paying so much send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show new sponsor today for the David
Pakman show today's episode made
possible by Blue Sky binary a forex
trading is a huge space millions of
traitors around the world 80% of those
traders lose money in forex and usually
it's some combination of lacking the
appropriate knowledge maybe relying on
others like traders or auto trading
platforms instead of themselves getting
emotional taking big risks maybe not
following proper money management rules
and blue sky binary offers their
education course and they are a leading
financial education and tech company
specifically focused on forex they've
got senior traders with actual trading
experience and they offer a really well
structured and self-paced course in
forex to help with all of the above the
course includes video on-demand online
tests one-to-one sessions and access to
their community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and our viewers
and listeners can get a one week free
trial at blue sky binary.com / David not
only does it include access to their
training platform but also you get a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics of forex trading afterwards
it is $99.99 a month if you want to
continue you can stop and resume at any
point
check it out blue sky binary.com /d AV
ID